hi it's with us in Los Angeles hey hi
and how are you hey it has begun
better than I deserve what's up I have a
face best question also a potential
based question as well 90-mile going
back to going to ecology and going to
avocados in Sydney Australia and I am
twenty two thousand dollars in debt and
I calculated it and I'm about six months
of living expenses saved up and I have
to work and make a certain amount each
month this to survive in Cindy I'm just
warning if that's a good decision to
kind of take that honor like should I
just pay my debt in full before we go
back to school so you're going back to
school why um I kind of like it's got
cost less to go back in a leadership
ministry certificate and kind of go into
ministry looking pastoral and preaching
that kind of demeanor okay so you feel
like you're being called a bit pastor
and you want to go get this is
effectively a seminary yeah yeah that's
a seminary yes right and so why why do
you why Sydney I kind of call me to
Australia I'm going to Hillsong earlier
now it's the church I'm involved in and
it's been kind of a while and I like the
columns in my life like us oh it's a
year so now I kind of fight it I thought
of a while I'm selfish I give again
unless God's called you in the ministry
I think that's wonderful the thing you
want to remember is this there God can
you can go forward at ten years old
kneel at the altar and God tell you that
you're gonna be a missionary
guess what he doesn't send ten year olds
so what that means is that call that was
really God's voice that spoke to that
kid when he was 10 years old but the
timing wasn't God's timing so God's call
is different sometimes than God's timing
and the geography might be different so
I don't doubt your call to the ministry
I am questioning Sydney and but if
you're a hundred percent sure that's God
in Sydney that's fine then I'm
questioning the timing because I will
tell you this if you have to go in debt
to do it it's not God
because there's nowhere in scripture God
used debt to fulfill his call ever it's
not in Scripture any not one time I've
studied for 35 years and so it's not
God's God called me to go into the
seminary and to go $60,000 in debt to be
a preacher no he didn't yeah I might
have called you to be a preacher but
didn't call you to do that seminary for
$60,000 in debt something's off with
your timing or something's off with the
way the detail of how you're fleshing
out God's calling in that example
okay now you didn't tell me you're going
into that to do this but you didn't tell
me you're too broke to complete it much
paint seascapes I can like if you
couldn't get through it with no more
debt then that solves part of it but God
never asked us to do something that's
contrary to Scripture
he's never inconsistent with Scripture
ever and if you think you heard that you
didn't hear God so that's what I'm
looking at and that's where you look for
your timing so is it ty is it there's a
consistent with Scripture is the timing
right and is it really God's voice and
is that peace that passes understanding
if so how about it dude have at it this
is the Dave Ramsey show hey guys thanks
for watching if you enjoyed this video
click the subscribe button to get the
latest content and check out these other
great clips from the show
you
[Applause]
[Music]